episode 57 of game programming that's
what's up my name is Turner and today
we're gonna talk about well we're gonna
talk about game programming that's what
we're gonna talk about today big
surprise there
so last episode I left you guys on a
cliffhanger and I don't know just just
to mix it up a bit you know cuz it's fun
to it's fun to do that it's fun to make
you guys suffer know it's it's more or
less I'm being serious here by the way
it's more or less it's fun to it to
actually solve things yourself which is
why I like Connor I might do that more
often not like in the crude cool sort of
fashion that I did last time we're
welding the game didn't even function
properly but I do like the idea of
letting us all things as elves because
that just involves the community a lot
more and it is entertaining so mxx said
not sure what kind of username that is
but literally mxx said in the comments
section of episode 56 actually pretty
much resolved the cliffhanger so shout
out to him or her actually mxx said it
so really a male-female name but um for
solving that that problem now we're
gonna implement it a bit differently
than what he or she wrote we're actually
going to well first of all we're gonna
talk about because you guys really have
no idea what I'm talking about so
basically we had this problem where we
opened up the game and we just went on
the map and why we one of them out why
again let's talk about that now
so what what you might notice right is
that we are we actually return if we if
we go over here right in fact if we just
don't go over here what's gonna happen
right is if this if this statement isn't
true right so if this statement is not
true right the compile world of games
going to go onto the next line of code
which happens to be this one and run it
because it's not returning this return
obviously means that it actually exits
the method in this case it returns this
data and then it does not run this back
code is not ran or run that code is not
actually executed if this salmon is true
right because it returns
so in other words what we should put
here is let's just say good right so in
other words if good is actually printed
that means that at some point in this
thing dislike this code and lower has
actually you know an executed so in
other words if good is printed out here
in our console that means that for one
of the tiles it has not returned the
void tile
so in other words let's take a look here
and you can see here in the console but
that's just not the case good is never
printed so what does that mean that
means that this statement is always true
so in other words that tells us as
programmers to actually take a look at
this statement and try and make sure and
just check it for errors so you can't
really go wrong with x and y because
that's the only way to input it and we
actually did do that earlier and that
worked fine all right on less than zero
zero is a static number right it's not
like a variable it's just a static
number is a constant so there's nothing
really to check there however we've got
width and height and they are our
variables so there's most likely
something wrong with them so if we come
over here we say oh okay here we go
check check of the cell this is our old
constructor that we used when we are
made randomly generated levels so
apparently we actually entered a width
and height and we said this table width
equal to that width so in other words if
we wanted a randomly generated level
that was 64 by 64 tiles big then we put
64 here and 64 here and that worked
beautifully but now we've got a 16 by 16
size image that we actually lowered all
right so is that actually like being
applied here at all and it looks like
this is our other constructor not really
all right width and height does do not
actually equal that so let's go into our
spawn level since that's level while we
look where we load this thing and over
here you'll see that yeah we do actually
define the width and height I remember
the width and height of our image is
equal to the width and height of our map
in tiles so in other words pixel 1 pixel
is a one-to-one scale here where one
pixel in the image equals one tile and
again
so all we need to do here is say that
apart at the NW because remember we use
that here is equal to width right and
image don't get worth so what this is
going to do is it's basically going to
make a new variable called W which is an
ax and W is going to be equal width
which is going to be equal to image like
get with so in other words this line of
code in case you guys having trouble
understanding is literally the same as
this line of code all right these lines
of code this line of these lines of code
exactly the same as this one line of
code all right
kyoool and now if we were on our game
here you can see that we actually spawn
in the top left corner because the top
left corner is 0 0 and you can see how
we've got this map now and it's just one
map awesome so that is basically how the
map gets loaded I know you guys gonna
hate me unless I give you guys some more
content in this episode so we're gonna
take a look at one more thing and that
is actually customizing the player spawn
location I saw they came up on a reddit
thread on my subreddit so I thought I
might answer that I don't know someone
probably answered it there but um
because I obviously know all you guys
cache that I'll um I'll talk about it
here so you'll notice it right now we
actually spawn in the top left corner
now why is that and the reason that
actually happens and they're with me for
a minute cause I gotta open up my image
to show you guys why that actually
happens so here we go if we open our if
we open our level file in paint.net
you'll actually see that if you if you
mouse over that area which is right over
here you'll actually see that over here
right it says 0 0 when I mouse over
there yep you can see that at 0 0 that
is the coordinate of that lovely that's
why we spawn there because our players
position is equal to 0 0 and that could
and that part of the map is 0 0 as far
as the as far as the map is concerned so
that's that's why we spawned there now
in the player class
and by the way it's not comment about
this I press control shift T to actually
open type which means I can just pretty
much search for glasses and open them
all right so ctrl shift T is the shock
off of that you can see here that we've
got in X and in Y right so what we can
do here is actually in-game so we made
this constructor a while back but what
it does is it actually changes the
location of our entity of our player
entity to be you know whatever we
specify here in the parameters so if I
actually go back to our game class where
we instantiate this player I can just
add I don't know like 30 comma 30 right
and run this and let's see what happens
oh look at that we're on the top-left
corner anymore where over here which is
awesome so in other words I can totally
customize how all that works like maybe
set this to like 200 this one to maybe
like I don't know um 250 220 somehow
that and if I run it you'll see that
I'll actually spawn there now that's all
cool but what if I want to spawn in the
middle like what if I want to spawn in
the middle of a particular tile so in
other words here you see the way
actually if I just clear these and set
them to 0 0 you can see that we sort of
spawn there what if I want to spawn on a
particular tile well all you want to do
there is you know the tiles are 16 size
big so if you want to spawn let's just
say let's just open up our level again
if I want to spawn right on this rock
here this is actually gonna be really
hard to do because I'm it doesn't have
coordinates learn to open them I don't
know again alright cool so if I want to
spawn on this like a little rock here we
can say that rock has coordinates 6 for
so and because we know so 6 comma 4
right yep so 6 x + 4 y and because we
know that the tiles are 16 like 16
pixels large we can simply go 6 x 16 4 x
+ 4 x 16 4 y this is very basic math but
um some of you guys might not be aware
and if we launch this you can see that
we spawned right on that rock so that is
sort of how you adjust the player spawn
locations again that'll be very very
like important and crucial to our game
in the future but that's also basically
how we're going to be loading maps and
from now on so what I need now is I
actually asked you guys a while back to
send me tiles to send me spreadsheets
and a lot of you guys did which is
awesome but if there's anyone out there
who thinks they can make a tile sheet
that will contain all sorts of tiles for
a role in the manticore type game one
thing I didn't actually check that I did
get some really high quality ones but
guys if you send me ones that you make
or you find make sure that they are
actually like copyright free so in other
words make sure that I have permission
to use them all right that's very
important I don't want to get like I
want to get in trouble so yeah but
otherwise we'll start on actually making
our spawn level probably next time and
then we'll talk about things like
collisions and that sort of thing and
maybe some lighting as well but I'm hope
you enjoyed this episode of game
programming if you did hit that like
button
let's get 200 likes guys I'm serious
punch that like button lets get 200
likes if you guys are enjoying that
series I appreciate it a lot if you guys
hit the like button and I'll see you
guys next time glad you guys
you